[Music]
over the past five years we've seen a
dramatic spike again poaching every
single year that we've had there's been
a great new record that's been set it's
an illegal multi-billion dollar trade
that relies on a sophisticated global
supply chain to cross borders and
continents it's a criminal network
[Music]
fueled by vast sums of money tangling
feature suit which goes for
approximately 1,750 US dollars eighty
ninety percent of rhinos horns as fake
people are blending money selling their
house to buy a buffalo horn it can go up
to a hundred thousand USD for four
kilogram
it's rallied an army of activists
celebrities with senior politicians now
pushing big business to clamp down on
high-speed trade routes there are things
that can really be done by people from
operating cruise ships to Airlines to
moving containers it's a market
sustained by age-old beliefs and a
surging middle class in East Asia when
people desperate and they have money I
think they they will do everything to
open the window applause for them
it's a story of the fragility of
institutions in emerging markets as well
as if the challenges of globalized world
brings to international law enforcement
upon our movement and I'll give away
fifty
didn't so came to London and to
conserving some of the planet's most
magnificent beasts as well as some of
its most unassuming killing seems to be
fairly unstoppable it's the fight to
stem a rapacious network of supply and
demand a tale of trading creatures both
great and small Kruger National Park
South Africa home to some of the
planet's most noble and most endangered
species but this is also a battleground
the frontline of a war on a global
illegal trade in rhinoceros horn that
sources it's rare and protected products
in this bush with the aim of delivering
its goods to buyers thousands of miles
away this rusty wire fence is a frontier
between South Africa and Mozambique in
recent decades thousands of people have
poured across it every year in search of
a better life here in South Africa but
in the last few years some of the people
coming have been plying a far deadlier
trade the poaching of rhinoceros in
Kruger Park has reached epidemic
proportions in 2007 just 13 rhinos were
killed in South Africa but such is the
demand now that last year the number
rose to twelve hundred and fifteen
nearly 5% of the global rhinoceros
population
there are five species of rhinoceros the
largest and most numerous the white
rhinoceros is the biggest of all land
animals after the elephant its habitat
along with its close relative the more
aggressive black rhinoceros ranges from
central to southern Africa but its prime
sanctuary in the last century has been
in South Africa when 90% of black and
white rhinoceroses are to be found
rhinoceros horn is extremely valuable
commanding prices up to a hundred
thousand dollars per kilogram on the
black market more even than gold such
demand has led to a second slaughter of
an animal that's roamed the planet for
millions of years from the 60s to the
90s as demand soared in increasingly
prosperous parts of Asia relentless
poaching reduced the population of black
rhinoceroses from an estimated hundred
thousand in 1960 to about 2400 in the
early 90s since 2008 after a 15 year lao
rhinoceroses are again under attack the
financial rewards on offer are often too
tempting to turn down for the many
impoverished Mozambicans
living close to the south african border
tracking suspicious footprints such as
this is one of the most effective
methods Park Rangers use to follow and
catch the poachers who are willing to
risk their lives for a rhinoceros horn
you have entrenched poverty in rural
communities and Mozambique where many of
the poachers are recruited also in
communities around national parks that
have traditionally been excluded from
national parks and historically excluded
from national parks very easy recruiting
grounds the money is ultimately at the
key you know you you have poaching gangs
being paid anywhere between twenty
thousand grand sixty thousand I've heard
figures up to a hundred thousand to go
in as a gang and carry out a poaching
incident poachers travel from towns such
as Mugu de some sixty kilometers from
the south african border they're hired
by middlemen from disparate networks who
travel to these rural communities with
vast amounts of cash to offer the
willing foot soldiers the incoming
wealth is on display in new villas with
satellite dishes and foreign cars
springing up in recent years alongside
the more traditional village
infrastructure
the poachers traveled by night on foot
and at speed into South Africa there
they'll track and shoot rhinoceroses
before removing the horns with knives or
axes and making a quick retreat back
across the border before Park Rangers
can catch up with them up to a dozen
gangs are believed to be operating in
the park at any one time with incursions
increasingly taking place across the
parks western border from poachers based
in South Africa the poachers returning
to Mozambique become the responsibility
of commander Cibola who heads up a new
national task force dedicated to
wildlife protection the FT met with him
and some of his team at the border
they're not the most scary this
murderous carry to do some 220 poachers
have been killed in the Kruger since
2008 one of commander su bolas team has
had repeated first-hand experience of
their firepower in 2013 his unit was all
but overwhelmed by a force three times
the size a group of 12 poachers they
started opening fire on us so we had to
run after those guys while they were
still shooting and then when we saw that
the situation it was worse then we had
to take a cover we carried alone you
know
firing but because we were using
shotguns and they were having a que for
this event 375 for five days so it was a
difficult
it's a relentless attack that frequently
overwhelms the limited resources of the
Rangers and security forces trying to
protect the park they are disciplined
they run like you the wind they walk
four kilometers and kilometers they
spend night art living off bread and two
liters of water I mean there they hide
in termite mounds I mean you know odd
Falk burrows when they feel that they
need to hide for the night their
discipline
thousands of miles away in Hanoi Vietnam
is capital the release of fish welcomes
the Chinese New Year such traditions
loom large in this fast-growing emerging
market once a province of Imperial China
Vietnam is now like its powerful
neighbor a single party socialist state
which is embraced to get rich quick
culture and where the newly affluent are
keen to splash out on ancestral
traditions one such tradition is Chinese
medicine a practice that has become
notorious for its use of the body parts
of endangered species although China and
Vietnam have officially banned
rhinoceros horn in traditional medicine
hearsay has helped promote it as a cure
for cancer people here in Vietnam
believe in rumors
it probably because of like for many
years we didn't have enough information
and so when would this rumor of this
random one killing that person spread
out people immediately bought it and
they they make the demand increased so
fast that the number of rhinos being
killed in the following years really
rocket
three times four times and it's not just
medicinal use that activist groups are
up against rhinoceros horn which when
ground and drunk has properties similar
to aspirin has become a status symbol
for some in the newly prosperous
Vietnamese elite me or anyone around me
would know someone who works for the
government who uses rhino horn they use
it for fun so basically if they have a
company retreat a year-end party they
would have the rhino horn so out for
everyone to use because they believe
that it it has that magic of as a viagra
and everybody knows that but people just
don't cannot bring out the evidence
because well I don't want trouble
Southeast Asia imports thousands of
rhinoceros horns every year mostly from
South Africa from the poachers villages
they're transported out of Mozambique
and neighbouring countries through major
ports
or on commercial airliners bound for
Asia the horns over 9,000 since 2008
according to one estimate are often
carried in hand luggage with Korea's
bribing their way and working with
corrupt officials they're then sold to
kingpins operating across Southeast Asia
many in Vietnam and it's not just
rhinoceroses that a feeding Southeast
Asian demand nestling in the country's
northern hills these extraordinary
creatures find a much-needed sanctuary
even more reclusive and far less
assuming than the rhinoceros these
mammals the most illegally traded on the
planet are now all but extinct in parts
of Asia also face a murderous assault
the only mammals to be covered head to
toe in hard scales the 80 million year
old Pangolin is an anteater that grows
to about the size of a small dog there
are eight species in all once living
throughout the tropical regions of
Africa and Asia the animal is prized for
its scales which in Southeast Asia are
seen as a cure for anything from cancer
to acne and can fetch six hundred and
fifty dollars per kilogram on the
international market it's meat is also a
delicacy one kilogram sells for about
two hundred and fifty dollars data on
Pangolin populations are scant but with
some three hundred and sixty thousand of
the animals estimated to have been
poached in africa in the last three
years
numbers are unquestionably in freefall
after years of turning a blind eye to
the problem the Vietnamese government is
at last officially tightening up with
new laws but it's still remarkably easy
to find and by Pangolin in markets such
as this one in Hanoi just 15 minutes ago
in a shop just down the road behind me I
was offered illegally a packet of
Pangolin scales for one hundred and
fifty dollars this trader was more than
happy to talk about Pangolin scales and
their medicinal uses with both hard and
soft scales on offer and it wasn't just
in markets where we saw Pangolin for
sale
porcupine Wow crocodile at a restaurant
in central Hanoi we found a wide range
of tangling dishes on the menu
one month about 10 the 15 Pauline okay
Oh miss miss miss me
for health again yes okay makes you
stronger
yes danke the near extinction of
Pangolin in Southeast Asia has led to a
dependence on imports now as with the
rhinoceros it's traffic from Africa here
in Johannesburg where similar
restrictions apply Pangolin scales used
by local traditional healers are also on
sale harvest rates out of africa have
risen exponentially within the last four
years so we're looking at serious
amounts of money 22 tons of penguin
scales in last three and a half years
easily accounts for 16 and a half
million u.s. dollars and that's only 10%
of what we intercepting so easy 160
million US dollars in the last few years
and it's the trade levels are rising
exponentially so we can explain expect
tenfold in the next few years
the sheer size of the trade raises
serious questions about the competence
and ability of Lauren forces to tackle
the problem with such high volumes still
crossing the huge distances between
source and consumer is it time for a
rethink in the battle strategy against
the trade in illegal wildlife parts
early morning in Kruger on the frontline
Ranger mark Montgomery is demonstrating
one of the tactics deployed against the
poachers dragging the parks roads at
sunset helps to reveal their tracks the
next day so this is quite a simple
weapon to use against the might of the
poachers definitely it makes the last
summer so difficult to forget to walk
across a road not once a week on average
it could be a fine tracks in area it can
be more depending on the amount of gangs
in the area as well
better cross-border cooperation is
helping the Rangers there's even a plan
to create a giant cross-border park to
help pool anti poaching resources but
incursions are still rising up 27
percent in the past year and the
poachers of course are just one small
part of a far bigger criminal system
[Music]
in Mozambique commander Cibola readily
concedes the real problem is
apprehending the bosses who the poachers
answer to and who oversee the next phase
of the trade Ellis tends to sound corny
a panade and Egon Arden on d-day can
tomando fortify caprara zoom and entity'
for yells preocupa penis envy a Gurkha
some profit in serious academic honesty
much noise times a treble and histology
- tisha practice solution is no
significant antonyms consonant deke a
stoical abandoned my Segundo call Desi
Arnaz Alina Celeste is a key part oh so
this confirms the calcaneus tackling
non-terminal aprama don't put them
but the bloody history of poaching in
Africa in the last decades suggests that
policing supply is at best one part of
the solution ultimately attitudes must
change in countries where the rare
animal parts command such a premium to
men is one of Viet Nam's most successful
pop stars she's joined the small army of
celebrity ambassadors campaigning in
China and Vietnam to sway public opinion
it's not easy to convince them something
is a right thing or something is wrong
thing but the younger people they might
like a like white paper plain paper you
know I heard from a little boy that he
knows and he saw his father take a small
piece of rhino horns home and use it
I asked him later whenever you see we've
gotta buy it use it what they're gonna
say you say and he said oh I'm gonna say
please stop it this is the wrong thing
to do
because if you buy it to anymore you'll
be killed yes and you know but that is
our future there are reasons to believe
that the tide may be slowly turning
after years have planed down the issue
Hanoi next year hosts a summit on the
trade but the record remains dire
activists point to high-level
involvement in Vietnamese customs and
security forces just as investigators in
sub-saharan Africa have exposed the
complicity of local officials in the
trade celebrity ambassadors may help but
political pressure on national
governments is the key whilst the stuff
on the stage is useful without a doubt
what's far more useful is for those
world leaders saying to the viennese
Prime Minister why why don't you just
crack down on this this is a tiny thing
it's a few people it's causing a lot of
drama in other countries it's not a
great thing for your country as it's
starting to invest more and more in
Africa and so forth you know it's of no
cost to you really to do this the
killing of Cecil the lion by an American
dentist in Zimbabwe sparked outrage over
the plight of Africa's big game and the
place of hunters in the debate over
conservation for global campaigners the
fuss was somewhat misleading far more
important is how to crack down on the
criminal networks international agencies
have long struggled to get to grips with
criminals who span borders whether
trafficking drugs people or wildlife
parts to date only one high-level
rhinoceros horn trafficker a Thai
national has been caught the data is
clearly telling us that whatever we're
doing now isn't working isn't enough and
that we need to be innovative in many of
the countries where this is going on
legal systems are not necessarily that's
well resourced and I think it's also
just a simple matter of priority not
seeing the problem for what it is
condoning it wildlife crime is about
much more
and wildlife crime and that's how we
should see it it also goes to rule of
law in countries it fuels corruption it
fuels money laundering it fuels tax
evasion so it eats away at the very
fabric of society
one proposition on the table is to
legalize some trade in ivory and rhino
horn the pro trade Lobby argues there
are lessons here from the war against
drugs by flooding the market with
stockpiled rhino horn you lower the
price disrupt the illegal trade and
generate revenue for local conservation
but many veteran conservationists
disagree what that completely ignores is
the huge number of aspirational users
that there are in Asia the other thing
is that if you're going to legalize a
trade you have to have it between two
countries that are basically not corrupt
there there's very very good organized
policing law enforcement and in our case
between here in China I don't believe we
have either in either country so I think
that you know you so what do you what
you'll create is you'll create a legal
trade which will run parallel with an
illegal trade and no one will really be
able to tell the difference in the UK
combining celebrity and political clout
former Foreign Secretary William Hague
is heading a campaign on behalf of
Prince William they're seeking to
persuade shipping companies and Airlines
to police more effectively their
customers in cargo it's all around the
areas of sharing information of
improving methods of detection of
raising awareness within those
industries I I get the feeling it's not
something they've that the industries
that the commercial organizations have
ever really thoroughly focused on before
we've now brought together airlines such
as Emirates Airlines Kenya Airways
shipping lines such as masks they are
for the first time sitting around the
table really crunching through what
happens where are these flows of illegal
products and what can be done around
awareness information sharing and
detection in desperation South Africa
and other countries are completing a DNA
database of remaining rhinoceroses and
other endangered animals
there is also a new drive to ensure that
local communities share in tourism
revenue giving a mistake in the survival
of these species the stark choice the
world faces is whether the rhinoceros
will survive this latest onslaught or is
destined to eke out its existence in
zoos never again to roam free in the
wild every one of us are trying to do as
much as possible with what we've got and
the manpower that we've got but the the
influx is just so I I think if we we
continue the way we're going we who we
fighting a battle which is going to be
very very difficult to to get a hold of
I know the last thing I wanted to tell
my children is that I was there on my
watch the Rhino was lost forever
[Music]
[Applause]
you